citizens of the reject nation we're all
going to become real real boys and girls
today isn't that right john that's i've
been dreaming for this day all my life i
know you have you talk about it every
day all right ladies and gentlemen we
are going to watch pinocchio the disney
plus movie at the time we're watching
this no reviews have lifted so we don't
know if it's horrible or great so we're
going to be in different clothes by the
time the review starts so that way we
can formulate our opinion to the masses
i know we're going to react to this
right now nothing to influence the brain
other than you know other disney movies
that have come before including the
original pinocchio film so guys leave a
like that'd be very much appreciated
also subscribe and click the
notification bell to get notified when
our reaction for something comes up that
you might enjoy
fooling through action watch alongs for
pinocchio and many other shows that we
cover exclusively are at our patreon
page reaction huts and watch long's
included for super sexy rejects lastly
the team at prepper thank you for
helping us edit down these highlights
let's swing into action
[Music]
my travels took me to a quaint little
village
[Music]
i love his little cricket song each jump
hmm
not too shabby
you are canceled well i think he looks
very much like him
very much
looks like the drawings that's for sure
please sell me a coco
that clock is not for sale as i have
told you many times i will give you 20
lira but if you cannot sell your clock
so why do you have a shop it's
complicated
i like the half italian accent he's
doing
what is your name
now what should it be huh
what should it be
dead boy
son two pine bokeho
do you love the name pinocchio yes yes
huh
live action geppetto seems insane
he's a little kooky he's probably
schizophrenic no
no why
because he likes you
[Laughter]
even cleo thinks he's very very handsome
[Music]
that's a hard fish that's a very hot
fish
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's the wall of branded clocks i had no
clue they would do such a thing this
movie just got awesome
all these other properties
love it
it's it's the wishing star
star lad star right first star i see
tonight
i wish
i i wish
i wish i may
to add more ips to the wall
i want the rights to warner brothers
clocks if i was to tell you he would
think i was
a drunk
this is italy in the 1800s
you could
kill a boy and stuff him you could just
kidnap someone else's kid stitch him
back together man
[Music]
jumping jeepers he's alive
you can rest easy when you're drunk
all right all right
all right all right all right everyone
can relax i'm here now what seems to be
the oh yes i see what the problem is
[Music]
that's very not a wedding well is this
having a blue fairy
a good geppetto made a wish from the
depths of his heart and so i'm here
i'm the blue fairy i'm the blue fairy no
i'm the blue fairy no i'm the blue fairy
oh i see what the problem is here
if i only had a brain
henceforth you are the high keeper of
the knowledge of right and wrong and a
trusted counselor during moments of
temptation
arise
sir jiminy cricket oh new threads
your dreams
[Music]
[Laughter]
hell yeah
pinocchio
i sure did all right i heard something
too and now that you can
hello pups
[Applause]
[Music]
my god doesn't stop
it doesn't stop
i wish that my i know
a real boy
but guess what i'm almost a real boy and
i can become one i think what he really
wanted was a resurrected boy
the almost real boy
[Music]
and so
pinocchio became part of geppetto's
little family
[Music]
he put that boy to work
they became a stable well-adjusted
household pinocchio
maybe it is time for you to go to school
really father really
you might want to prepare the other boys
for what they're getting into man i'll
be fine
i will be right here
when you get back
we will eat dinner precisely at the
stroke of fine
got it father the stroke of five
let me go
you're hurting my hand getting
uncomfortable
that boy's gonna freak out some kids
i would i would chaperone him for his
first day out in the world yes well
going to school it would be good for him
huh school
jumping jeepers what time is it
ain't nothing more dangerous to a
conscience than a trip to school this
little puppet is running around loose on
the streets without a conscience can you
imagine the trouble he's gonna get into
well i wouldn't want that on my
conscience okay mr right or wrong hold
on to your hat
was this supposed to be a 3d movie i
could see that
stromboli
so that old rascals back in town gideon
remember the time i tied strings on you
and passed you off as a is that keegan
michael key
[Laughter]
apple being original remake being [ __ ]
okay
i'm going to school so i can learn a
bunch of stuff to be a real boy and make
my father proud a real boy why on earth
would you want to be real
when you can be
famous
amos yes famous but i want to be real
yes yes my boy but did you know many
people say that you're not actually real
until everybody knows about you this is
true has such a personality such a
profile such a physique why he is a
natural-born actor right gideon and not
just an actor an entrepreneur
an influencer
and won't your father be proud that was
in the original script that's right
[Music]
i feel like this movie's still a work in
progress
they're testing it on us now son
remember what i said about temptation
well that's him oh no that's mr honest
john he's my agent honest john pinocks
as a rule of thumb when somebody calls
themselves honest
they ain't especially if they're an
agent
[Laughter]
i want to go to school oh get out
school is for real children
it's a miracle of god yeah
you should be bowing down to this thing
an atrocity i don't think that teacher
likes no who cares what he thinks his
pedagogy is completely outdated is it
you know when i saw tread for this i was
like
it should have been the theaters
like
this looks like a disney plus movie yeah
once you see it on a tv it becomes clear
i present to you something that you will
absolutely refuse to believe
the toy
who thinks he's born
so this movie is really like a
commentary trying to monetize anything
[Music]
look at that miracle look at that idiot
look at that stupid miracle
you can't stick your nose in every plank
that comes your way
i'm not tied
[Music]
we can build children without having to
give birth yes
just gotta find that wishing star every
night
that nose expands you don't wanna put
your ass up there man
i i have made fire it's a tribute to the
original story where they burn his legs
off
i was actually attributing tom hanks and
castaway i
have met
[Music]
[Music]
what's this nonsense nobody in my show
performs for free now pack we live in an
hour
and you
you got to pay for that
oh my little pinocchio
i was scared to die to get lost or
stolen
we would want that now would we
you know know where we go
oh [ __ ]
i seriously think the secret director of
dumbo directed this
stromboli is a horrible me man but we're
going to help you leave me alone
we're going to figure out a way to get
you out of that cage
did you hear what i said
we're going to help you
pinocchio look at me you were seducing
me with your puppet
distracted me mr stromboli said i could
go home and tell my father i got famous
but then he locked me up ah
so now you don't trust anybody well
i trust you
sort of thank you
wait till you find out the truth about
her
we puppets and puppeteers are going to
take back the money stromboli stole from
us and escape
and we will treat all the members of our
troop fairly and kindly and poop
no strings attached
dude that woman's very good at her job
yeah her ability to project her voice
like that in this weather
and to do the whole like ventriloquism
like not moving your mouth much
over here
i can't believe you're so close
[Music]
i really think you could have probably
still leverage underneath
through the wet dirt learn to dig
lifted it up jiminy
i never wanted to be famous
sorry kiddo that's not the way i
remember it
but i didn't want to be famous i wanted
to go to school
it's true
all of those people cheering and
applauding looks weird in live action
imagine that in 3d
believe me
[Applause]
oops okay that last part wasn't true but
everything i set up until then
you know watch
they say about guys with big noses man
you guys seen the first episode of the
boy season three
oh no
jiminy is almost the right size you know
i don't want to be a real boy
i had to reach the key i'm sorry jiminy
being real is in your heart that's what
being real is all about keeping it real
i'm sorry i didn't listen to you outside
of school
[Music]
it's the weirdest griffith observatory
movie i've ever seen
presented an imax
you've got to be careful because
sometimes when peter's getting a group
they like to pressure
there's that polar express christmas
carol direction i was expecting let's
get some chaos going
straight a little one boy
look at him he's made out of wooden
sleds
i'm landwich
your name sled let's see his face
pinocchio
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
guys you kids are behaving like a bunch
of
jackasses
you were on the corner see it got
collected
oh okay
but i need to find my conscience
conscience what's so funny you
your conscience is a loss
is that luke evans it's the greatest joy
joint in the world
no cops no parents no rules you can tear
the place apart and nobody says a word
my god
very fortunate that you're coming with
us
because pleasure island will be the most
life-altering experience you will ever
have
well mr coachman it sure sounds fun
but i don't trust you
[Music]
ah you're hitting like a horse's ass
smacking asses jiminy cricket you tried
to fall and ruined it for everyone
[Music]
real boys always want
the fair point
okay then
i say we all
go
peer pressure accomplished
welcome
to pleasure island
come right inside enjoy the ride and
suck the show there's so much fun here
holy [ __ ]
and no one
[Music]
dead men tell no tales
here you go gents ever tall one they're
on their house better yet have two
bottoms up
that sure looked like luke evans
[Music]
wow
[Music]
wow
that kid's crazy
[Music]
we just killed that boy down there
fleeting out from the ground
this is like every amusement ride in
disneyland can bind into one
definitely back in polar express
territory there's not even a track here
to ride
it's just that well-designed
[Applause]
that's pretty cool
degrade
school great puns on pleasure island
right in the keister
that's for sure and third degree burns
same looks like my father's clocks
oh yeah
watch this
[Music]
is this where pinocchio is
oh my goodness
this is a serious crisis
a catastrophe pinocchio went to vegas
they shot all tom hanks's teens in a
week
i wonder where everybody is
holy moly heapers
[Music]
[Applause]
i
don't remember those yeah that's freaky
how come you didn't bust any of them
cuckoo clocks it just didn't feel right
wasn't the mr goody two shoes
well i guess you ain't transformed into
a complete jerk yet i don't want to be a
jerk i want to be a real boy some boys
already difference yeah
i wish i still did have a conscience
pinocchio
this poor cricket i know
some thanks i get
[Music]
oh brother
it's like i've dropped into h e double
hockey stick
satan's [ __ ]
[Music]
you gotta do what you gotta do to win
you're wrong lampee i still call what
you did cheating you'd think something
terrible was gonna happen to us
what's in this root beer
wow he's smart to put that together
really fast you sound just like a
donkey that come out of me
my god is a body horror movie
cronin nokio
help me please anybody
anybody please just tell anybody
[Music]
ugh
i remember this
you embrace the new look make it part of
your show
[Music]
[Applause]
wow that 3d is so real
it's like it's popping right out of the
screen
[Music]
let's call those tails wooden
bollocks
a wooden donkey would have been worth a
bleeding fortune
an assault mine would it
father it's me pinocchio i'm home
maybe he's asleep
you know what i love about this movie
you can tell roberts and mecca's really
put his heart into it
there's hardens hole into this sailed
out to sea am i not speaking clearly
sophia how how do you think in a boat
he needed to get to pleasure island to
look for pinocchio so he sold all his
clocks and he bought a boat
oh
way to go pinocchio
life's work
you know what you becoming a real boy
can't replace those goddamn
clocks i don't see geppetto anywhere
i hope i'm wrong but that sure looks
like stromboli's to me
quick under the pier
blend in with the wood yeah pinocchio
this is how you kill a man
this is how you make a shiv
learning to survive on the streets is a
cricket if you lie and then cut off the
tip of your nose
[Music]
pinocchio
no
way
is that what happens in the movie
i think this character is like created
for this movie
you started your own puppet show we sure
did last night the carabinieri arrested
stromboli and put him in jail
wow
i have to stay in and find my father
pinocchio something tells me the
decision you made is the right one you
didn't even question the donkey ears man
this world is so used to the weird [ __ ]
live puppet boy live puppet boy half
donkey
talking animals yeah i had the
promorphic fox
perhaps i'll see you next year when we
come back to put on a show in siena
a pinocchio
[Music]
until next year
[Music]
she is such a good
marionette puppeteer i know the way she
can project her voice she can do a
perfect show from anywhere
[Music]
no boats nothing only water as far as
the eye can see we'll find him positive
thinking
i mean pinocchio swam to land no problem
yeah
and he's like a speed boat
[Music]
hello
i see a tiny boat a tiny boat yes a
dinghy a dinghy
did you hear something
figaro
why would you bring your cat this is a
miracle
pinocchio
i'm coming to you but no i'm coming to
you
[Music]
hey a figure oh look he can run on water
well of course he can run on water he's
making them wood i'm coming for
pinocchio
jesus christ was made of wood you got
kicked out of school
for being a puppet so i joined the
puppet show became famous you became
famous
yes
and now we're here
you did all that in one day
my goodness i haven't done a fraction of
that my whole life
i'm sorry father i apologize for all the
trouble i caused i didn't think he was
that far away
now we can go home again and we'll be
all together
where is it
now that would have been cool to see in
the theaters wowie
that one shot was pretty sweet yep
[Music]
he's asleep wake up my friend's in there
open up your big bumper
father
father
you got swallowed
[Music]
what a relief
that's the only way to kill him you
gotta fight him with wood
oh i'm so happy to see you oh i'm so
happy i feel like this movie just
started getting good like 15 minutes
ago finally coalesced
it looks to me like everything comes in
but nothing
goes out except the other way
presumably but that is not a good option
you know geppetto i don't feel like you
really gave a [ __ ] about your cat
you've tortured it
you're always putting it in harm's way
you
unnecessarily brought it on this
adventure
[Music]
i i have made fire
open up i need to get in there open up i
say
open sesame
well what do you know
hot boxing
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it always was good at those like
animation tracking
[Music]
he's
shots
to get irritated by the smoke it must be
tickling his nose
[Music]
oh boy
[Music]
you know jiminy sometimes i feel like
you're just getting in the way
it's that cricket is your conscience
[Laughter]
i'm quite upset by that
[Music]
that's the way it looks so silly
and yet it's like so breakneck pace
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
oh no
now he's gonna be lost on an island
gotta give him cpr pinocks
gemini thank goodness i thought you were
a goner look he sneezed us back toward
land
[Music]
that it's actually quite terrifying
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's making the engine sound i love it
we're going 80 miles an hour pinocchio
[Music]
surprisingly
scary holy [ __ ]
oh my god
figaro
whoa
father talk to me say
something
figaro is here
and cleo
don't die father
please don't die
why did pinocchio learn about death
today
your dreams
[Music]
[Music]
true
[Laughter]
oh
i dreamt it weirdo been swallowed by a
whale yes father but it wasn't a whale
it was a sea monster and we got out
this big lovecraftian tentacle whale no
i remember you saved us
this woke pinocchio stuff changed it
from a whale to
not my monstro
you honestly did try with all your heart
and that makes you a truthful boy and
you know what else it makes you
unselfish and very very brave
that's all the things you need to be
there isn't a single thing
i would change about you
i am so very proud and i love you so
very much
i love you too father
[Music]
pinocchio
do you know the way
we'll follow that light
so in the end pinocchio did prove
himself brave honest and unselfish
and then he turned into jonathan taylor
thomas
but i do know one thing for sure
in his heart
pinocchio is as real as any real boy
could ever be my god it was just about
him accepting himself oh
doesn't that what he doesn't even need
to be real
he is real
[ __ ] what is real anyway
coward
scream play by zemeckis too
that's right man did he just rewrite a
few lines and you know ad added the the
character or two that the higher-ups
decided they needed to add what is this
ending credit font that semekis loves so
much
it is so
generic know it's odd
and it's almost
normal
it's a great opportunity over here to
make credit scene of
walt disney walking into gepetto's shop
going
i don't want your clocks
i want those characters you i want the
rights to all of your characters
in the second post credit scene just so
this movie really just triples down
as he does turn into a real boy he turns
to a real black boy
[Laughter]
and i was like i just don't know i don't
think it's weird i don't think you're my
actual
i don't know i don't think you're my
real boy
go back to the pub what do you mean dad
there was a jeremy johns listed as
producer man's moving up i feel like i
had one of those dreams i barely
remember i know
and then i tried telling you just
someone i'm like i had a dream that
there was like a live-action pinocchio
movie yeah there was like
a bunch of disney clocks and uh he and
michael key and then there were
pleasure island and looked a little
weird oh jiminy cricket was gordon
dude
and luke evans got some pipes on him
he was also in the live-action version
of
he was gaston in uh the beauty and the
beast yes and
and he was dracula untold yes and
yes and he is uh shaw's brother in the
fast and furious yes
but he's also in he's also
in
i know it's hard right what else is he
in
okay how many disneys have they wanted
you who was it i don't know
oh okay all right oh wait there's a big
one he's in i know there's a huge one
he's in okay um
uh
luke evans movie is a huge one huge luke
evans movie it was not a luke evans
movie but he had a big character in it
yes
yes he did and i could almost see it
but it's not coming to mind it's a big
character big big like like physically
big
no it's just an important character okay
not not yet like important but not a lot
of screen time character no he's he does
have a lot of screen time okay
clearly this is getting me closer to the
answer
um
i'm gonna hate myself when i hear what
it is you will
a big one
oh
jeez i don't know how you're not
pointing i know is it a sports movie
no might have been in a sports movie i
don't know isn't luke evans in
somebody's football movie or something
um
golly
god this is really embarrassing for you
i know fast and furious dracula and told
beauty and the beast what else
cameron toss a coin to your witcher
who sings that
the bard
oh my god i don't know how you're not
getting this is like the easiest clue i
could have draw for you
now i'm just thinking about the witcher
i'm just thinking of which or character
if i give you another clue it's gonna be
too easy okay um
[Music]
it's that it's that kind of era
like i'd say so fantasy yeah you know
okay uh it's not dracula told
does he have long hair in it yes he does
okay um
that's how you're gonna be upset when
you realize
i'm already upset i'm already upset
because i because i don't want to drive
anymore because i'm like there's a
really big reason why you ought to be
pulling this right now my mind's eye
there's a spotlight but there's just
this like fuzzy shadow on what the
spotlight is actually illuminating
this movie
and he's one of the better parts of that
movie too he is one of the better
characters in those movies he's the man
from the lake town who has to get all
the people together okay all right wow
yeah
yeah okay his name bart
or is it bart i think it is bard
that's good yeah yeah yeah
that's good
we got there we made it now we did
now if we can name one more luke
[Laughter]
this one and that's it
that's okay he auditioned for that one
movie and that was a start
never climbed his way you're hired
and i got a whole slate of movies for
you
i don't think there's a post-credits
scene something tells me there's not a
post-credits scene something tells you
robert zamekos
wanted it
[Laughter]
such a strange
combination of visuals and pastes
oh man
terribly pace well yeah it's it does
really seem like in a rush to just like
okay we got this character we got the
scene we went to this place when it's
that play all right kids you happy all
right we're done
ugh i mean the classic pinocchio's um a
classic okay yeah yeah
all right so there's some of these songs
are definitely original yeah i don't
like i don't remember the i remember
like
literally the main plot points of
pinocchio
yeah puppet show
donkeys whale
yeah pleasure island you're a kid and
you get that rush of like oh it's a
jackass it's a kid's movie yeah no i
think they added some stuff here
plenty
which really helped the movie it
really helped it breeze by
i saw the movie growing up a number of
times it's definitely been a long time
since i revisited it and i've been on
the ride several times and the ride is
like a great glyphs note to the movie
that's what this felt like it does
everything felt more like one of those
um
4dx rides at universal studios yes
made a pinocchio like a ride that goes
on a little too long yes and isn't as
impressive as it seems to think it is
yeah i was like this is a glorified
simulator yeah exactly this is a 3d
model you're in a theater full of a
bunch of people just shaking around
things are poking you yeah
yeah
exactly the occasional fog effect
yeah
yeah
i was trying though i was trying i tried
some stuff
i think i don't care
how you really feel
i i i don't i really feel like robert
zemeckis uh really phoned this
like
i'm shocked to see his name attached his
top billing for writing credit like holy
balls
you wrote this
yeah i i don't feel like you did you
co-wrote produced and directed this and
and from the outside part of me was like
well this seems like a perfect robert
zemeckis movie and and something that
would play to his clear predilections
for animation cgi motion capture all
that jazz
and his sense of heart and whimsy and uh
and yeah it's so weird i didn't feel
i loved the movie uh trailer i loved the
trailer yeah yeah i thought the trailer
was awesome um and i was like oh damn
this could really be something special
yeah this could bring him back you know
tom hanks reuniting that's a that's
amazing
i'd be so surprised if people
really i mean we're not the target
market i get it but didn't chip and
dale's just win some [ __ ] i think you
won an emmy for like best tv movie or
something like that oh my god i needed
the witches too
i mean i can't i liked
looking at his filmography here oh god
oh yeah he's got jiggle back from the
walk
so his last truly well-received movie
was 2015.
yeah
and that
you know is based on a true story that
probably doesn't require a lot of the
[ __ ] that he loves to do
you just watch him lose lose it over
time
it is a bummer and he is one of those
guy i like i i've heard a few people in
life say that like cgi
is one of the worst things to happen to
tim burton and you can sort of chart the
change in his career as he as he
discovers and really starts to use that
and i feel like you could apply a
similar theory to robert zemeckis
well while they added a couple of things
here which i thought i don't really
remember i don't like i said i don't
remember i'm just going to talk about
this movie for
what exactly it is because they
obviously added some stuff so it's not
just a 100 shop or shot remake even
though a lot of times it is just
doing what the original animated movie
did
um
it uh felt
the pacing was yeah it just felt like
it needed another pass on the script and
he didn't have another pass on the
writing uh needed another pass on the
editing it really seemed like to me yeah
uh it was just kind of
it was moving so fast and
i don't remember the original enough to
get lost in oh yeah i remember the
original look at them doing the original
[ __ ] like i'm just not lost enough in it
because if it was exactly like the
original then i'd be like they just they
were the original
and so it's kind of like a uh unless
they really expand upon it and i just
found myself going would really help
this is if it really took pinocchio's
perspective
and kind of adapted some of the wonder
to it um from his perspective as opposed
to just have a boy speak with an
inquisitive voice the whole time which i
guess is a lot like the animated movie
but you have so much more working for
the animated movie with the tone
um with the spirit and the and the
animation overall like aesthetically
provides just a completely different
emotion versus a combination of cgi
animation and live action it's not going
to evoke the same emotion other than
kind of reminding you of the original
animation yeah that's all it's really
going to do so you really do have to
kind of try to do some different things
here and the time i felt like it was
really singing for me personally
was when
uh in the last like 15 minutes of this
film
when they're at the waters and
and then
latino like girl shows up forever
she shows up
and the whale incident and like the
comedy with
with uh like when they're kind of making
fun of what happened
and and it seems to have a
it seemed to have a real fun sense of
whimsy
about it like it felt genuine in that
moment with a tad hint of you're in a
rush to get out of here but you know it
still felt like fun
where as
you know when you do i feel like
actually the opening scene is kind of a
major problem
uh with opening bits there's a common
major problem of this movie
speaks towards what one of the problems
of this movie is
is is the conflict of not really knowing
what to do and and you know you have
the opening which is so much the
original pinocchio film and then when it
started showing like the disney ips like
like you can't be chip and dale rescue
rangers though you know yeah
like it's it is so
you know it's so in your face too it's
so in your face and it doesn't do
anything to be like oh that's i feel
like there's a version of that that
could be like oh that's cute or clever
but it's just like no look at every
clock based on one of our properties
versus like oh here's one that you could
catch if you're looking really close or
something like that
it does scream remember all the stuff we
own yeah it's not even treated like a
clever easter egg it's just it's just
really
it's right in your face
roger rabbit would have been fine yes
because
and it would have been cooler if
i would it would have been cooler if
like you know it's one of those things
you're like wait a minute in the
background is that a woody one
yeah that would have been neater and
then you know people make their
breakdown videos and you're like holy
[ __ ] oh my god it seemed designed to get
people going i need to get one of those
clocks is someone on etsy going to make
one of those clocks yeah
disney gonna put those out
so what i mean by that is it it just rem
showed me
like okay this is that at odds with
itself of what disney does today and
disney of old and it doesn't know how to
be either one properly
and it was kind of to me that's just
sort of the issue with this film like
that scene in and of itself is not
really a problem for me
it's more of how this film plays out
because
a lot like pinocchio the animated one i
believe is a shorter run time than this
but like i said there's so much feels
more substantial and lived
and because of
all the other aspects that i was working
for it
versus here which just felt like
choppy and noisy and pinocchio instead
reads as like
not really i'm bored for his goals it's
like a weird thing to say about but okay
with the character really i'm not not
really feeling the the drive here for
you or the why like you know he's
determined i get it uh
there was an actual interesting my mind
trailed off quite a few times during
this movie but it trailed off
at one point and then the movie at the
end said something that i was like oh i
was actually thinking
this would have been more interesting if
they did that thing
when geppetto
is saying
i know you probably wanted to be to be
someone else you wanted you probably
wanted me to you probably thought i
wanted you to be somebody else yeah and
i'm sorry about that
but the truth of it i realized i what i
really wanted is you
and i'm like oh that was what i was
thinking what would have really helped
save this whole film yeah is if there is
kind of just an awkward thing in the
beginning
where geppetto and pinocchio where
geppetto like doesn't really quite know
how to receive it because there's so
much emphasis on i molded you after my
son
yeah
who i am not able to let go of and my
wife who you are also a reminder of yeah
i know it's a little dark but i think
like teeter a little bit there just for
your setup you know it's human and
and then deal with but he's not my son
he's like this
strange thing that's that's come to life
and then pinocchio feels like i have to
prove myself yeah and become a real boy
to get my father's approval then
geppetto feels responsible for why
pinocchio
is
running off on his own now and trying to
do his thing like if he decides to go
because now that you're adapting that
you got to adapt it yes
you know and that means change some and
if you change some of those core
ingredients for your live action weird
hybrid
then you got a real movie on your hands
that could have the tonality and the and
the sweeping heart
uh that way when you get to the end you
feel like there's an arc for both of
these characters
because i'm like i don't really know the
arc was here they kind of said a lot of
[ __ ] that i was like it doesn't really
feel like
what did you learn necessarily well yeah
i feel like there could have been an
opportunity like the as i recall the
original pinocchio there is this quality
of yeah he he
finds his way out into the world and is
swept up in this sort of revolving door
of these different people and places and
and life sweeps you up like that and i
think that yeah at the outset
you could have had you know he's
obviously being uh you know preyed upon
and he's having ideas putting his head
by people around and if you had not made
it so that the
when he leaves the house the adventure
is on and we're going and i feel like if
you had a little bit of back and forth
of geppetto trying to wrangle you know
his boy going out into the world for the
first time you could easily set up yeah
that emotional back and forth of like
he's trying to guide pinocchio on the
right path but pinocchio doesn't
understand and he is very trusting and
naive so he wants to go experience
certain things with you know all these
people that he's meeting and you could
have yeah an easy way of getting it to a
point where geppetto is blaming himself
for pinocchio leaving and pinocchio
yeah thinks his dad doesn't understand
and then ultimately learns you know what
he was trying to communicate the whole
time and you wouldn't have to get super
deep or complicated about it but i feel
like this this did move in such a way
where you start out in the scene with
geppetto
and that scene is like different from
the entire movie because you just spend
that whole
10 15 minutes whatever it is in one room
if you didn't know you might be like oh
is this one of those play movies yeah
exactly it takes place in this one yeah
this is tom hanks and it's you know then
it's the the it's uh figaro and cleo and
him and and that sets you into this
really kind of gradual beginning and
then once pinocchio comes to life it's
just like mad cap and we're just moving
moving moving
and it feels very episodic and it
doesn't give you time it's like even
though as i recall again the original
pinocchio movie does move you past you
know it's like not every character that
you meet comes back you kind of spend a
little interludes with each but each one
leaves its impact and each one feels
like it's part of this fantastical
journey whereas this doesn't give you
hardly any time enough to it just feels
like a bunch of lights and colors
whizzing by you yeah rather than yeah
anything challenging for the character
it's just a quick it feels oddly more
cartoonish this movie because it feels
just like a bunch of peril thrown at the
character
and there's just like stump like random
stumbling into [ __ ] yeah and then
they'll break on occasion to be like
peer pressure or or to say something
kind of like very obviously on the nose
to like strike a theme without really
like living the theme
and and even understand i'm not sure
zamakos understood pinocchio
and it's weird because it's not that
hard to understand no it's not and even
even when you're at pleasure island like
you have the donkeys people are
transforming and being shipped off to
the salt mine and there's really you get
like a couple scenes that demonstrate
that and there's smoke monsters and then
once you leave there there's nothing
about that ever again and so even the
the you know punishment of that even the
sort of like oh it's too late and now
you are doomed because you've given in
to you know all your vices and desires
even that doesn't really have much
impact because you know once he leaves
it's it's done and then he tells a
couple of good truths and then his ears
go back to normal and it just feels like
everything's always going to be fine and
like even when they wind up inside of
monstro it's like we were both i think
sitting there going like okay like this
is this creature looks pretty scary and
the scope is really convincing
and then they're only in there for like
a minute you know like i feel like you
get to the sense in the original that
they're in there for a while and they
think well this is our life now we're
gonna perish in here oh wait no we're
gonna find our way out what salvation
whereas here it's just you know sort of
another thing it's just like well we're
in here and uh okay well we gotta get
out let's come up with immediate
solution and uh
it feels like jiminy cricket is the
actual lead character of this movie
because and i thought there was the
thing they were setting up for jiminy
cricket that would have they were going
to do different too i kept writing what
i consider a better movie
no yeah i'm a pompous [ __ ]
well i was like oh is jiminy cricket
guys kind of looking out for himself
and and he's like all this fear about no
i don't want to like learn like oh what
if he has to learn yeah what if he has
to really accept being the conscience
and i mean you know they could have made
an actual like interesting
movie here out of like with real i'm not
saying make your petal like an abusive
dad or some [ __ ] just like i don't
really know how to adjust to this this
is this is exciting at first but you're
not real uh you should probably go to
school like it could have been like more
of a perilous world you know instead of
just being like all right yeah just go
to school
well that thing too he's like it's just
weird in live action you just came to
life last night hey go to school today
i'm not gonna walk you there or or be
there for any of the process i'm just
you know i think he was alive for a
little bit of time right like they had a
whole montage of him doing [ __ ] i guess
so uh but
still his first time being like oh what
is that that's his son pinocchio yeah it
was cool
well even so you would think he would
want to at least i don't know accompany
him
to the first day and maybe maybe realize
that it might be a risk being like
here's my anthropomorphic puppet son and
he might not be fully understood by
everyone i know that this is the most
integrated you know 19th century italian
village
uh but at the same time
yeah it's
it just undercuts like the actual
relationship and the actual care and the
reaction to the live-action doll come
you know puppet come to life from from
the world this inhabits like gepetto's
like
and everyone's like oh cool
yeah yeah you could you can make me
money or yeah you don't belong in school
like everyone just looks right past the
fact of what he is which you could have
made into like a charming little bit or
something you know you could have made
something out of the misfitness of that
and then played even further up you know
the other people in the stromboli show
or the other folks you know headed to
pleasure island
even that like that uh the uh i'm
blanking on the kid's name offhand but
you know the like his buddy at pleasure
island doesn't even really feel like
you're really with him he's just kind of
a kid who's near him a lot
no it's like i think you could have kept
the same run time and just kind of
cut out a couple things and then
expanded upon a couple of other things
and you would have had a pretty solid
solid film that would have felt
different
than the original yeah and honoring the
original two and
simultaneously i think you could have
done something that does both that would
have just made this more interesting
instead i felt like this is surprisingly
boring
it's yeah it just doesn't it doesn't
have a pace and it gets bogged down in
the way a lot of zemeckis films do the
recent ones do for me in yeah feeling
overly mad cap and overly like a chase
like there's always like some kind of uh
yeah like over-the-top shrill sort of
chase element and pinocchio himself is
so
like i i was torn constantly because the
voice performance is so dear and so
childlike and so sweet but it's also
kind of one tone the entire time and
like not that i never felt for it but
i felt like you too could have also
really made pinocchio feel like a real
character
yeah
and that's what i mean like having a
having a contemplation and wanting to
get dad's approval and
because this whole movie is like i want
to make my father happy yeah and
and and like oh what an interesting arc
it would have been for him to just
realize like he doesn't have to strive
to just make his dad happy yeah i should
still be honest and and brave and and
kind but also i need to find my own path
and yeah even if my father's worried
about me i can't live only to that tune
and it's funny to me because i i would
love to know what the difference is over
at the disney camp between the reboots
like these that they do for the movie
theaters that you can tell they're gonna
sink tons of resources into
versus these ones that clearly have
means and money but that
i don't know like there's i think they
wanted this to be a theater release
originally if yeah because it's all of
them but it looks like a made-for-tv
movie oh yeah it came or streaming movie
slightly above me
yeah yeah yeah
and even that like again not to not to
slight robert zemeckis but even even
this didn't really feel like
we were talking about video game cut
scenes and stuff like that and there's a
lot in the camera motion and just in the
visual storytelling
that is moving and is choices but that
doesn't really feel like it's a tone or
a distinct style for this movie oh if
anything i like the i like this a lot of
those shots like they're they're my
favorite parts of the action moments of
like polar express and a christmas carol
i've never seen beowulf
um but that's the moment but those two
movies that i have seen from when he
ventured into the animation realm
um you know beyond roger rabbit he
directed roger robert right he didn't
just produce it
i'm pretty sure he directed roger rabbit
um yeah
i sometimes you know you get those
confused yeah directed by him okay you
know like sometimes like corpse bride
yeah quarterback no oh actually henry
nobody ever knows this is henry selling
correcting half of the things
yeah yeah
um
and so uh yeah when
uh when those moving shots happen a lot
of times it's like these these slow kind
of circle around and you stay still and
then character kind of gets jerked into
something yeah and you follow them
through
like that's or adopts a perspective for
a moment when you're like under water
and you're swirling for a minute or just
getting like yanked around or some [ __ ]
yeah
and and spielberg did the same thing
with i'm pretty sure he probably called
up his buddies in mexico for uh tintin
and now i got some advice yeah yeah
applied some of that too in ready player
one there's a very specific type of uh
locked off shots that they do that i
really i enjoy those shots a lot like i
just think they're really cool shots
and
and while i like that yeah there is not
a really distinct flavor to this
it felt disjointed and clumsy and i like
uh
i'd like
it i like tom hanks for the most part
even though i feel like he was kind of
like [ __ ] we're here i'm getting paid
let's have some fun i'm just gonna make
up an accent committing to my my snl
sketch with a little more heart like
come on yeah well let's do it
yeah like i don't feel like he like
built it like geppetto from the ground i
i feel like he read the script and was
like all right i'll do it i'm gonna do
my tom hanks thing and i'll put on the
mustache and i'll kind of come up with
an accent and we'll call it a day i'll
be as sincere as i possibly can but i'll
have fun with it but i'm not gonna spend
ages coming up with backstory no no yeah
i felt like uh i liked the if anything
that some of the surprise performers
were the ones that they liked a lot the
uh
uh oh my god i'm ready for his name the
the the one who first kidnapped
pinocchio and put him in the show
stromboli stromboli yeah it was good
giganomic key actually did a really good
job with honest john yeah the voice work
not that the character really stood out
and i think jose gordon did a good job
with the voice workers jiminy cricket i
liked him a lot yeah and and uh i didn't
like the sabine character yeah yeah i
thought she did good and i loved the
whole thing with the marionette and the
french accent and that i was like maybe
this new thing because they always got
to add a new song or something and i
kind of liked the song and i was like
maybe this will amount to something but
she just kind of shows up at the end and
she's like hey we're good we got we got
the puppet show yeah later i didn't
unders it felt like a weird like
playstation video game like like the
playstation like a bad kingdom hearts or
some [ __ ] yeah i feel like they finished
the script so i said it was so early on
like i feel like this movie's not
finished
yeah and it's like they're like it feels
like there's some some scenes or beats
missing and they already did and spent
the money on like a bunch of set pieces
and things yeah so they're just like i
don't know use what we have and it's
maddening because i'm like this
this should have worked and it shouldn't
have been that hard to make it work like
robert zemeckis seems like a great
choice for this i like the cast they
assembled uh you know the that blend of
cg in real life is
perfect for this
you see the trailer and you're like this
is of all the disney remakes this seems
like a good idea yeah
and uh and yeah marx is a real boy
which i kind of like that change i'm not
gonna lie there's something cool about
that change yeah actually too yeah
because he doesn't have to be for the
emotional resolution to really take hold
like that's i feel like that's one of
those things that like
that's the reward after the emotional
resolution in the in the original movie
i would say
um so yeah you don't necessarily need
that reward i was surprised that the
blue fairy never came back or you know
followed up with jiminy cricket
um
but yeah because she comes back and
helps at one point right yeah i think so
she like makes an official conscience by
the end and she says i can't help
i think oh yeah at the very end i think
she like i think she comes in three
times
i think at the beginning and then at one
point to help out again and it's like i
can't help you out though you gotta do
this on your own some [ __ ] like i forget
what no no i think you're right i don't
remember it doesn't matter
they probably saw the backlash for
cynthia riva and they're like we can't
upset her all right she was great like i
ugh like that is like the least of
anyone's worry about this film truly and
i thought she did a great job she was
great i liked her scene i liked the
rhymes i liked the that was when i was
thinking like okay the whimsy is is
gonna work you know the
the fun speech and the rhyming and the
music and the even the effects on her i
thought were really lovely and
celestial
you're so much kinder than me i was like
15 minutes in i was like i i think it's
gonna be bad
i mean yeah there was something there
was something
in that early scene like i was i was not
out of it in the opening but there was
something where i was like i do feel
like i'm just kind of watching tom hanks
do his thing while somebody let the
camera roll on rehearsal i feel like he
remembered his lines today
yeah
yeah it just never feels like a real
movie
i i don't think about a real boy never
managed to feel quite like a real movie
to try to make because i was like it
looks off about the effects so because i
i we were watching this on the computer
and and so i i was noticing like oh it's
on game optimizer mode so some of that
motion smoothing happening
so i changed to filmmaker mode be like
okay this will probably make it look
better
and it kind of
which is weird yeah
in a world like this
i don't know if it helps or hurts
but yeah and i mean you know props to i
i do i do feel like oftentimes that
added character like
this kind of reminded me of a really
short version of the tim burton dumbo
which has a lot of similar issues and
that was a movie where
it was like ah these human characters
that they added in are so tedious and i
get the it's funny for all the people uh
you know freaking out about pinocchio
i was like this didn't really uh like
the girl they added in sabine
you don't know like even even that that
felt like the most natural thing in the
whole movie weirdly enough what would
have been great for pimvocio is if
at the end
he get the blue fairy comes to change
him and to a real boy and he says i'm
actually a girl
[Laughter]
that whole time right with that
don't gender my little wooden child
i think they should have re-shot it just
for that that would have been hilarious
just to piss off people
oh see that's the thing is this one does
have moments where they do break the
fourth wall and they're like you're you
could be an influencer
peer pressure that's what i mean and
that's a big part of what i mean is like
you can't you can't be both with this
movie no and those things especially
feel so tacked on
in a way that it's distracting and and
and that is more distracting than having
a black blue fairy or having you know
like a there isn't literally added with
a disability or whatever if you have not
seen the original pinocchio
like i've seen the original pinocchio a
few times
and i'm not like at
all feeling like it calls attention that
it's a black fairy
no not not one she shows up and does her
thing one part of me is
is like something looks off she's a
[ __ ] fairy it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter you know i would say like
it's it's sometimes if you do a a race
swap thing it there is a part of my
brain that can be like oh i'm aware that
they've raced like sometimes that can't
go off or a gender swap like it can't go
off and then i adjust actually i think
it's like the difference for me is like
i can just adjust really fast
when that little bell goes off in my
head like oh i'm a little bit aware that
they've swapped
here i'm like i
i don't
it just does it doesn't even there's
nothing to
there's nothing to be upset about like
there's a little early there's nothing
to like it's just it yeah i i i can't
even like find the words right now
because it's so
it's so it's such a issue it's so like
not it's so not a problem that i don't
people made it a problem
it does nothing to the story and yeah i
mean disney can be a culprit of shoe
horning instead of naturally
incorporating inclusivity they they can
shoehorn that stuff and yeah it doesn't
feel like that here
because it doesn't call attention to it
and again it doesn't matter it has no
effect on anything oh it's guy wrote
rogue one oh goody
and he wrote the original he wrote
cinderella the
one of the good live-action disney i
think people really thought they had
something in the bag here that would
have been a grand slam hit but
yeah i'd be surprised if
you know i wouldn't be surprised if like
we get an audience score that's like
phenomenal that is not review bombed by
a bunch of racists
but i would be
you know like i would be i wouldn't be
surprised if like the critic score is
terrible and the audience score is like
still fresh maybe not like super high
64. 64 70s even yeah um
but i think kids will like this
yeah i know that's the target
demographic but come on chip nails
rescue rangers wait
and not that this needs to have that
kind of tone but yeah i mean you could
have easily made this a quality story
and something sometime joy sometimes
people really lean on some [ __ ] to
forgive things if you're like it's just
for kids or
it's fun uh you know it's just really
the tone you say it with it yeah for
kids
[Music]
um let's not be in such a cringe
but we all know that fun movies can be
more than just fun and kids movies can
be more than just kids movies and the
truly memorable ones usually have a bit
of both elements and for a movie that is
clearly in the trailer itself clearly
playing on the ones that many adults
grew up watching yeah um i think they
they should they could have done them oh
this is a better job just as much for
the adults who's
this is just as much for the nostalgia
disney adults as it is for a new
generation of children that was awful
i'm watching a lot of like things
it roll the dice
yeah no i feel like i shouldn't watch it
i don't like
all right guys well here we are um what
did you think about this uh you know
what i'm saying the movie did you love
it
was the best movie in the world i hope
you thought so
and i'm trying to pull we'll re-make
sure you want to hear
don't you don't need to place your
patreon for this movie what's your
picture
thanks go to the patreon menu there we
are there you go
shortcut like there you go all right
oh we didn't write it down yeah not yet
okay all right
we're doing a patreon day shout out
all right andrew has john selected you
andrew hayes because if anybody at our
patreon could fit the bill of a puppet
come to life it's you my friend
i would love an andrew hayes puppet just
to have you know like oh hey how's it
going i'm doing a dance i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna unlock here i'm gonna be
a locksmith it's your house we're gonna
go to pleasure island and then you know
just have your all your little cute
little limbs on strings and stuff like
that and then make you dance control
your life make you resent me i don't
know you just have like an adorable
compact quality about you that i really
appreciate and i think that if this
movie had been about you going out into
the real world and experiencing the
breadth of opportunities but also the
breadth of treachery
it would have been much more engaging
would have had like a new jersey kind of
flavor to it but i think that could help
you know because uh this didn't even
really feel like we were in italy so who
cares
but i love you buddy i hope you're doing
well happy recent birthday and uh we'll
catch you on the next great disney movie
[Music]